KEVIN VALK: Hello everyone.
Welcome the Talks at Google.
I'm Kevin Valk.
And today we're welcoming
Miss Jane Lynch--
[APPLAUSE]
JANE LYNCH: Thank you.
KEVIN VALK: And Kate Flannery.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN VALK: So
you best know them
as Sue Sylvester from "Glee"
and Meredith from "The Office".
But right now they're
teaming together.
And they're doing a big
old tour for "See Jane
Sing" around the country.
They're going to be playing
up at UC Davis tomorrow night.
And then they have a big
line of shows the 16th
through the 19th of August this
month up at Joe's Pub in New
York City.
JANE LYNCH: Mhm.
KEVIN VALK: So awesome.
So tell me about the shop.
JANE LYNCH: Well, it started
out as, 54 Below, which
is a cabaret space
in New York, asked me
if I would like four nights to
do my act, assuming I had one.
I said, well, I
don't have an act.
But I will put one together.
So I challenged myself.
And I brought this one
on board immediately.
We've been singing together for
probably decades which is kind
of a shocking thing to hear.
And you know, I just started
putting songs together.
And we ended up with
about a 45-minute show.
And we had so much fun.
And we had a three-piece band.
And so that's how I met who is
now my manager, Steven Greener.
And that's now Deana's
my tour manager.
And everything just
started falling together.
And we have a five-piece band
, the Tony Guerrero quintet.
And they are frigging
amazing you guys.
They are masters.
And then this other
dude, Tim Davis,
who was the vocal
arranger on "Glee",
became a very good friend.
And he joins us.
And we do these really
tight three-part harmonies.
And wow, we're having a blast.
KEVIN VALK: Wow.
So what's your favorite part
of the show in terms of--
is it the live audience?
JANE LYNCH: The live
audience and anything
I do with this one.
KATE FLANNERY: Hey.
I was going to say
the same thing.
KEVIN VALK: But you
guys know each other
from a long time ago.
Because you grew up in Chicago.
JANE LYNCH: Uh-huh.
KEVIN VALK: Outside of Chicago.
You grew up on the east coast.
But you guys were--
JANE LYNCH: Came together
at the Annoyance in Chicago.
KATE FLANNERY: In Chicago,
the Annoyance Theatre.
Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: And you were at
Second City but after me.
KATE FLANNERY: After you, yes.
KEVIN VALK: Right.
KATE FLANNERY: But I was
Jane's understudy in the show
"The Real Live Brady Bunch".
JANE LYNCH: Yes.
KATE FLANNERY: But I played
all the non-Brady roles.
So we got to play together.
But then I got to watch her.
And so it was like a
weird science project.
JANE LYNCH: And you
were great as Alice too.
You did Alice.
KATE FLANNERY: I did Alice
for quite awhile, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: She was hilarious.
And we all came out
here at the same time,
all of us Chicago people
from the Annoyance theatre,
like in the early '90s.
And we started doing sketch
comedy and what is now
the UCB up on Tamarind there.
What was it called?
The Tamarind Theatre?
KATE FLANNERY: The
Tamarind Theatre, yeah.
Up on Franklin.
JANE LYNCH: Right.
And we did.
We would do these little,
like, sketch comedy shows.
And any time I wanted
to do a song of Kate
wanted to do a song
we'd grab each other.
And we've been singing together
for-- we did, "What a Pair".
KATE FLANNERY: That's right.
The benefit, yeah,
for breast cancer.
JANE LYNCH: Show for breast
cancer. "What a Pair".
And they have you sing duets.
And so she and I did a duet.
In fact, the song we did--
which Kate found, and we do it
in our show-- is Far
From the Home I Love.
Are you familiar with that,
from "Fiddler on the Roof"?
As it's kind of
an aching ballad.
Well, she found this
terrific tome about it.
KATE FLANNERY: It's like
a bongo drum version
that these two sisters did
on the "Ed Sullivan Show"
back in early '60s.
And it's like, it's the-- it's
the most insane, fantastically
musically interesting
arrangement.
JANE LYNCH: Has nothing to do
with the content of the song.
KATE FLANNERY: Nothing.
Nothing whatsoever.
JANE LYNCH: Which is, you know,
aching for the home I love.
But I love this man.
And it's just like,
you know, they're--
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: Shaking
their tits basically.
They're the Barry Sisters.
KATE FLANNERY: That's so true.
And what's funny is
that I thought, maybe,
one day I might get to lip
sync to it in a drag bar in LA.
But we get sing with a live band
and in front of other people.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, it's amazing.
And the harmonies are awesome.
And it's just this
great belting number
that in fact, it's kind of
physically taxing, this song,
the breathing and
everything, that we almost
pass out sometimes.
KATE FLANNERY: It's so true.
But it's worth it.
JANE LYNCH: We did it in Utah
where the elevation is so high
that we literally had to be
sucking the oxygen off stage.
We're like, but we stopped
in the middle of it.
We had to stop in
the middle of it.
Jesus Christ, this elevation.
But it's a really fun song.
KATE FLANNERY: But the
audience is worth it.
It's worth all the
pain we go through.
JANE LYNCH: Exactly
KATE FLANNERY: And really,
it's just, we just love it.
JANE LYNCH: We give and we give.
KEVIN VALK: Well,
I was going to say,
but what's so cool
about "See Jane Sing"
is that they're all really
small, intimate venues which
is awesome.
because the audience
really gets to--
JANE LYNCH: Some have been huge.
KEVIN VALK: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: We've
done some huge.
But and that's great too.
But there's something
about like, we're
doing it at Joe's Pub.
And how many is it?
Like 250 or something?
KATE FLANNERY: I think so.
It's pretty small, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: It's
like a supper club.
And it's kind of old school.
It's got the candle or
the lamps on the tables.
And you can order
dinner and have drinks.
And yeah, it's going
to be really fun.
KEVIN VALK: So
growing up in Chicago,
and you grew up, obviously,
in an Irish family,
with the name Flannery.
KATE FLANNERY: Right.
JANE LYNCH: So did
Lynch, by the way.
KEVIN VALK: Lynch?
Oh did you really?
KATE FLANNERY: Yes, Lynch, yes.
Yes, yes.
KEVIN VALK: Irish?
Look at this.
KATE FLANNERY: Oh
yeah, yeah, yeah.
KEVIN VALK: So was music a big
influence in your guys family
growing up?
Always present?
KATE FLANNERY: Absolutely.
Well, my dad had a
bar, Flannery's Tavern.
And then I went on to
play a drunk on TV.
What a stretch.
KEVIN VALK: Perfect.
KATE FLANNERY: But you
know, he had a jukebox.
And if you didn't
know a song, he'd say,
you don't know that song?
I remember him
always like, sort of,
you know, challenging
me to learn something.
And I loved old music back then.
Because that was like,
the way that we connected.
But I feel like
Jane's dad and my dad,
they were probably related.
JANE LYNCH: They would
have loved each other.
KATE FLANNERY: Were
probably related.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: Because
Ireland is so incestuous.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, exactly.
KATE FLANNERY: And so I'm
sure-- No doubt, right?
JANE LYNCH: Rapes and pillages.
And there are no pure Irishmen.
Yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah, but
when you talk about Frank
in the show, it's so great.
We get to do some songs
that you used to sing around
your kitchen table.
Which I-- it's fantastic.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: So when my
dad came to see the show
he just plugged right in.
He just loved
every second of it.
JANE LYNCH: Aw, yeah,
it was so great.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, her
dad is just a gem.
Such a great guy.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: But yeah, a
lot of the stuff that we're
singing in the
show came straight
from the kitchen table.
I used to sit around the kitchen
table with my mom and my dad.
And my parents who were
terrific harmonizers.
My dad sounded like Bing Crosby.
He had a beautiful kind
of voice, like this.
And you know, my
dad was a banker.
My mom was a secretary.
They were professionals.
But I went on to do it.
You know, I loved it so much.
KEVIN VALK: Wow.
And you did a turn on
Broadway in "Annie".
JANE LYNCH: I did.
KEVIN VALK: As--
JANE LYNCH: Miss Hannigan.
KEVIN VALK: Ms. Hannigan.
And so what was that like, going
onto the big Broadway stage?
JANE LYNCH: Oh, it was great.
You know, I hadn't
been on stage.
And I think the
same for you, too.
I haven't really done
a play since I started
doing television in the '90s.
So that's a couple of decades.
So I hadn't been on stage.
And I didn't think I
wanted to do stage anymore.
It doesn't pay that much.
It's real-- you know, when you
look, it's really hard work.
But you know, getting
it up every night.
And eight shows a week.
And I loved it.
I was reinfected with the bug.
And I couldn't get enough of it.
I did it for two months.
And it was such a joy.
In fact, that's how I met
the people at 54 Below.
I got into the Broadway
community, as it were,
and they just
assumed I had an act.
KEVIN VALK: Wow.
KATE FLANNERY: She was
the best Miss Hannigan.
I got to tell you.
She was hilarious.
She kind of reminded me of Lucy.
You were so funny.
JANE LYNCH: Oh thank you honey.
KATE FLANNERY: And
such-- oh my god.
Seriously.
JANE LYNCH: My biggest fan.
KATE FLANNERY: No,
I mean come on.
JANE LYNCH: Vice versey.
KATE FLANNERY: Like, just
plbb, home run like, plbb,
every night.
Cell phones, annoying people in
the audience talking, whatever,
selfies, you don't--
she was [INAUDIBLE].
She's such a pro.
KEVIN VALK: Is there a little
room for improv like that,
interacting with the
audience and kind
of calling them on that stuff?
JANE LYNCH: No.
No, not in that.
I was too afraid to step
outside of the bounds in that.
KEVIN VALK: Not Hannigan.
But I mean in "See Jane Sing".
JANE LYNCH: Oh, absolutely.
Oh yeah, yeah.
But what I love to do-- and I
know Kate does this too-- is I
like to script
every damn moment.
I build a cage.
But then I bounce around
freely within the cage.
I need to know that
I've got that structure.
You look like my
brother so much.
KEVIN VALK: I am your brother.
JANE LYNCH: Oh my god!
KEVIN VALK: You owe
me a lot of money.
JANE LYNCH: We found out
we're from the same part
of the country.
Like, you know, minutes
from each other.
KEVIN VALK: We're
both from Chicago.
KATE FLANNERY:
And are you Irish?
See we're all ancestors.
See?
KEVIN VALK: We're
both from Chicago,
I went Illinois
State University.
KATE FLANNERY: Oh
yeah, yes, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: Downers
Grove is where he's from.
Isn't that a hell of a name?
KEVIN VALK: Hell of a name.
JANE LYNCH: I'm
from Downers Grove.
But our show is
extremely-- I mean,
I've got even my
hilarious patter that
looks like it's off the top of
my head, I've scripted within
and inch of its life.
But then I do bounce
around within that.
Right?
And she's loosey goosey.
KATE FLANNERY:
Always, every city.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, nothing's
the same twice for her.
So and that keeps
me alive and going
what is she going to do now?
KEVIN VALK: Now, is it fun to
kind of get back into that?
Because you guys were both on
scripted shows for so long.
And so was it fun
to kind of get back?
Well, I guess you had a little
bit of improv in "The Office".
KATE FLANNERY: Not so much.
I mean, sometimes.
But again, that was a show
that was way more scripted
that you would have realized.
You know?
KEVIN VALK: Yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: But
yeah, no, totally.
I mean, and that's the
fun of kind of getting
to use these muscles.
I mean, we both started
out at Second City.
And like, I feel we were
there at such a golden time.
Even though we had our own
weird experiences withing all
that, like, the people that
we came up with, I mean,
I think about the people that
were there when we were there.
JANE LYNCH: Stephen
Colbert, to drop some names.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: And Steve Carell.
KATE FLANNERY: Nia
Vardalos, Amy Sedaris.
KEVIN VALK: Andy
Richter, Tina Fey.
Well, maybe Tina Fey--
JANE LYNCH: Tina
Fey, they're younger.
KATE FLANNERY:
Yeah, a little bit.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, that was
the next generation down.
KATE FLANNERY: But still, yeah.
And you didn't know.
I mean, who knew?
Like, the deadbeat.
You never know.
JANE LYNCH: You
were about to call
Stephen Colbert a deadbeat.
KATE FLANNERY: No.
KEVIN VALK: On the record.
JANE LYNCH: He did go through
a kind of a very meek period.
That's for sure.
Yeah.
KEVIN VALK: That's so funny.
So what has been some
of your favorite moments
just from the tour and
doing the show together?
JANE LYNCH: Well, this
one makes everything--
you know, we play off
each other very well.
But I just don't
know what you're
going to do a lot of the time.
And that keeps me on my toes.
KATE FLANNERY: I have
no memory of this.
JANE LYNCH: Because I'm
kind of a control freak.
But I love the
stuff you throw in.
And she knows.
I tell her all the time.
I couldn't do this
show without her.
KATE FLANNERY: Well,
Jane is very generous.
Because I'll tell you,
I mean, I feel like I'm
just there just to keep the--
JANE LYNCH: Ridiculous going.
She's insane.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah,
and just kind of keep
an extra ball in the air.
That's the thing.
It's like, you think
you're just going
to see this TV star who's going
to, you know, enjoy herself.
Maybe not more than you are.
You know what I'm saying?
JANE LYNCH: Hostage situations.
We all know what those are.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
But like, I love that Jane
has like-- she stepped it up
with an amazing band.
And then with Tim Davis, it just
takes a whole like, vocally,
like, there's so much going on.
And she could just phone it in.
But she doesn't.
You know?
JANE LYNCH: We have so much fun.
KATE FLANNERY: You
could email it in.
People would still enjoy it.
But she, you know, Jane
really works really hard.
And it's like, I
feel like, you know,
you get your money's
worth is what I'm saying.
It's worth it.
Seriously.
JANE LYNCH: It is.
And now it's a
little over an hour.
Which all the
promoters are grateful.
Because they were like,
you got to add more stuff.
And I didn't want to add
things just to add them.
You know the saying.
You know, do two or
three more songs.
And it was like, well, wait.
I just can't do two
or three more songs.
I need to feel compelled
to put them in.
And so now we're
actually over an hour.
If we did the whole show
with Tim opening and the band
doing their stuff we're
probably an hour 20 now.
Which at the promoters are like,
they're very happy with that.
KATE FLANNERY: Sell more drinks.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah,
sell some more drinks.
And you know, people want
to-- I understand it.
People want to feel like they've
had a complete experience when
you go out.
Because the tickets
aren't cheap.
We don't come cheap.
And we're not cheap.
You want to feel like, an
hour show and it's like what?
So you know, they do
a little intermission
depending on the venue.
Sometimes they'll
do an intermission.
But you do want
them to-- like, we
have this song,
The Party's Over,
which means the show's over.
And people are like what?
KATE FLANNERY: They
freak out, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: What?
We just sat down.
And so we've certainly
made it longer.
But like I said, I didn't want
to add things just to add them.
KATE FLANNERY: Right
and less is more.
Let's face it, right?
Honest to god.
JANE LYNCH: Yes.
And I've been a student of
less is more my entire life.
And I have sat
through those shows
where people-- where you
lose interest in the person.
In fact, you get angry at them.
It's like, if you do
one more song dedicated
to your inner child I'm
going throw something at you.
KEVIN VALK: Well, it
must be fun, also,
to bring Tim Davis out
from just arranging stuff
and actually coming and
being with you guys.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
Well, these two--
and I would say
I have a pretty
good ear too-- Tim
and Kate and I do these
really tight, crazy tight
three-part harmonies.
And then they back
me up sometimes.
I don't even know that
they're going to do it.
Like when I'm doing
a song by myself
and I hear them doing
the oohs in the back, ah.
And you just-- they
pick them up so fast.
KATE FLANNERY: We're oozing.
We're just oozing.
JANE LYNCH: Oozing.
KATE FLANNERY: Oozing love.
JANE LYNCH: And a la sometimes.
Yeah, so that's
what's great about it.
And Tim, indeed, is
a vocal arranger.
But she's-- holds her own.
She can figure out
her part like that.
And I'm pretty good at it too.
KATE FLANNERY: I usually
don't sing without a wig
on though, just so you know.
JANE LYNCH: But yeah,
it is great having Tim.
And Tim is a wonderful crooner.
And he's got a great
sense of humor.
He's a goof.
And he's a very handsome guy.
And he comes out in his
tuxedo and sings with the band
before we start.
Which is kind of nice.
And the band itself, they're
really entertaining guys.
And they have their own
special thing that they do.
And they're very funny.
KATE FLANNERY: They have
sort of an early '60s vibe.
So they're very well dressed
but they really swing it baby.
JANE LYNCH: Skinny ties.
KATE FLANNERY: They
swing it, man, you know.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, and they
say things like that's
bitchin' man.
KEVIN VALK: So what was
the evolution of that
in terms of coming up with
like, the idea to take it
into that era and do that?
JANE LYNCH: It all happened
that naturally and organically,
which is the best way for these
types of things to happen.
Tim introduced me.
I said I wanted a
three-piece band in LA.
Because it was out in New
York I had my three-piece band
originally.
And so I said, I
need a band out here.
He said, well, I
have a five piece.
And I was like, well,
can I use three?
And he says listen.
Just listen to them.
And these guys are amazing.
And it just-- our first
rehearsal just, I went OK,
we're taking all five guys.
KATE FLANNERY: It
was so interesting.
Every time we do a
show I feel like we
like each other more and more.
Like, we actually watch
earlier and earlier.
Like, sometimes,
you don't walk on
till you're about to perform.
So you don't like,
listen to other people.
I mean, some people do.
Selfish actors,
selfish performers.
JANE LYNCH: Not us, of course.
KATE FLANNERY: Not us.
But we actually, like, enjoy
it like, more and more,
I feel like.
Which is amazing.
Usually it's the opposite.
You like people less and
less when you tour with them.
So it's kind of like,
I said it out loud.
So now i jinxed it.
So now we're going to
go in the backslide.
But that's all right.
JANE LYNCH: But we do early
earlier and earlier-- or later.
Sorry, Is it later and
later in the opening act,
she and I are out there now.
What is the earlier?
We watch the whole
thing now I guess.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah we do.
Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: Space and time
is screwing me up right now.
But yeah, we go out and watch
them, watch the whole thing.
And it's so fun.
But also, we don't
do a lot of dates.
We're not out for
months at a time.
And I think that's when the
hate brews, is when it's day
after day, night after night.
Now we see each other, we meet
at the airport and we're like,
yay!
It's so great to see you.
It's a nice thing
KATE FLANNERY: Rare thing.
KEVIN VALK: You guys
have talked about your
sitting around the dinner
table and coming up, having
these songs with your family.
So what were some of your
influences coming up?
And what were some of
those songs growing up?
KATE FLANNERY: Well, the
Irish thing, like Bing Crosby,
of course.
I mean, just also
like, those early '60s
songs that my parents hooked up
like, songs from "My Fair Lady"
and like, I remember always,
like, singing doing the dishes.
That was like, the
showtunes thing.
But like, sort of very
specific-- I don't know.
I think that there's, of
course, like Frank Sinatra.
There's something--
there's like a zeitgeist
that we're hitting in a weird--
but it's much more eclectic
than just that.
Because there's songs from
Mighty Wind that we do too.
Anyway.
JANE LYNCH: So we
have, at one point,
I noticed that, except
for the Mighty Wind stuff,
we weren't singing anything
that was written past 1960.
And then are you familiar
with Flying Machine?
That group from the '60s,
they sang that song-- they're
a one-hit wonder-- "Smile a
Little Smile for Me Rosemarie?"
We added that.
If you come to the
show you'll hear it.
It's a sweet little pop song.
Most of the stuff is
of that zeitgeist,
of like, the '60s and '50s
and even back to the '40s.
And we do a song from you know,
Coney Island is from the 1920s.
KATE FLANNERY:
Right right, right.
Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: But we just
added Nicki Minaj "Anaconda"
for the kids.
KEVIN VALK: For the kids.
I was going to ask if
there's any of that--
KATE FLANNERY: She's a pleaser.
She's a pleaser.
JANE LYNCH: We knock it
out of the fricking park.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
She kills it.
That's a hard thing.
Holy crap.
JANE LYNCH: I do
most of the rap.
KATE FLANNERY: She does.
JANE LYNCH: But we do it, we
do the chorus in a beautiful
three-part harmony,
that is just--
KATE FLANNERY: We're so white.
Oh my god.
JANE LYNCH: And even the band is
like-- Yeah, it's pretty great.
And then to see them,
like, dancing, trying to.
We're so white.
KATE FLANNERY: We are.
JANE LYNCH: We're so white.
KATE FLANNERY: It's
never going to change.
JANE LYNCH: And we're like,
doing the street thing
as best we can.
So it's fun to watch.
KEVIN VALK: So is that where
all the ideas come from?
It's just from all three of you
guys just spitting out stuff?
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
KEVIN VALK: And so it evolves
throughout the whole tour?
JANE LYNCH: Right, like
oh this tickles me.
Let's do that.
Or the newest thing we're doing
that we're going to premiere,
we're doing University
of California Davis
over the weekend.
And I think you're going to
come, which will be great.
KATE FLANNERY: No pressure.
JANE LYNCH: And we will be
premiering our songs that
made us cry as children medley.
We were in the van.
I was talking about how, Puff
the Magic Dragon, when I was
a kid, used to make me weep.
The part about Jackie
Paper came no more
and oh, it just broke my heart.
I had a little phonograph and
I would play it over and over
again.
And I would be beside myself.
And everybody started piping up,
the songs that made them cry.
Tura Lura Lura, which
is an Irish lullaby.
For Tony it was a Seasons
in the Sun, Goodbye Papa
Please Pray for Me.
Remember that?
And Ben, Michael Jackson's Ben.
He ain't heavy.
He's my bro-- you're
going to be like,
on the floor
spiraling into despair
at the end of this medley.
So we'll be premiering that.
KATE FLANNERY: We
will affect you.
JANE LYNCH: Yes.
KEVIN VALK: Very cool.
JANE LYNCH: We will affect you.
KEVIN VALK: So do you guys
have any funny stories
just from the tour?
Because live theater,
everything's live.
So there's mistakes.
And there's little goofs
and stuff like that.
JANE LYNCH: Not really.
I know that everybody
wants to hear oh one time
the drums fell off the stage.
And we were like, what?
But yeah, no.
We don't really have
those things thank god.
Not yet.
KEVIN VALK: I just jinxed
it for tomorrow night.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
The drums are now going
to fall off the platform.
KEVIN VALK: Yeah, it's terrible.
You guys can start lining
up at the mics too.
We're going to start
taking questions.
So what is something that you
guys just haven't done before?
Like so you've
done live theatre.
You guys have done TV.
You've done improv.
Is there anything that you guys
haven't done before after the--
KATE FLANNERY: Porn.
JANE LYNCH: That we want to.
KEVIN VALK: Yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: Porn.
JANE LYNCH: Porn.
KATE FLANNERY:
Have not done porn.
KEVIN VALK: Porn.
I think Meredith, your character
on "The Office", was doing--
JANE LYNCH: I think
the next logical step.
KATE FLANNERY: Let me tell
you, NBC, no, very blurred.
My parents went through
a lot with that.
But it was very blurred out.
It could have been a lot worse.
No granted, the cameramen
never looked at me at lunch
when we shot any
of those scenes.
Never looked at me in the eye.
No eye contact.
But yeah, it could've
been much worse.
Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: You know what?
I don't have goals anymore.
I just don't.
I've found that they're
a waste of energy.
And what rolls in at my feet
is usually-- or you know,
like 54 Below's saying
come do a cabaret old chum.
And I said, yeah.
OK, let's do that.
So I enjoy that kind of a thing.
And then things
happen organically
and I'm not running
around like a chicken
with its head cut off.
Like what's next?
What's next?
KEVIN VALK: And do you
guys have a favorite city
that you guys have
done as New York--
because I mean, New York
population is-- I mean,
JANE LYNCH: New York's OK.
KEVIN VALK: Broadway's there.
Eh.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
It's no LA.
JANE LYNCH: Well, what
was really fun, we did--
[CHEER FROM AUDIENCE]
JANE LYNCH: Exactly.
We just did Beverly Hills.
Which a great theater, the
Annenberg, it's a new space.
Kind of a new space.
It's about five years old.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: What
a great space too.
And so all of our friends got
to come, some of our family.
And the band, most of them
are from Orange County.
So their wives and
kids all came out.
And that was great.
KATE FLANNERY: And Dick Van
Dyke sat in the front row.
JANE LYNCH: Dick Van Dyke
sat in the front row.
KATE FLANNERY: And stood up.
And oh my god, I was so nervous.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
Yeah, that was enormous.
KATE FLANNERY: Why did
that make me so nervous?
JANE LYNCH: I wish we had
that-- the reason I had "Smile a
Little Smile For
Me Rosemarie" is
because when I used to watch
"The Dick Van Dyke Show",
Rosemarie.
The actress, used to
break my heart because she
didn't have a boyfriend.
Well, Herman Glimsher,
but he couldn't commit.
So I thought that song Rosemarie
was for her, for her character.
So I wish that I had had that
when Dick Van Dyke was there.
KATE FLANNERY: I'm sorry.
He so loved it.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, he
was quite pleased.
KEVIN VALK: Well, while
we're in that era,
I kind of want to talk about it.
Because you sang with
Carol Burnett on "Glee".
JANE LYNCH: Yes.
KEVIN VALK: And did you
guys do that on tour too?
Did so she come?
JANE LYNCH: No.
KEVIN VALK: No, OK.
JANE LYNCH: No,
we didn't do that.
KEVIN VALK: I mean, how
incredible was that?
JANE LYNCH: Yeah,
pretty outrageous.
And pretty much one of
those things where you go
is this really happening?
KEVIN VALK: You sang
the Trolley song.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, we
sang The Trolley Song
from "Meet Me in St. Louis".
And we also sang the Ohio
Song from "Wonderful Town".
Wasn't it "Wonderful Town"?
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
And she chose them.
Because when she was
on the show Ryan always
said-- he gave her kind of a
what would you like to sing?
What era would you like to sing?
And then she got to
make the final choice.
So yeah, it was really great.
It was a lot of fun.
She's a great human being.
And I grew up watching her show.
And she inspired me.
I didn't know I wanted to
do sketch comedy so much.
But I knew that
kind of fun that she
was having, that kind of
creative fun, was what
I wanted to do with my life.
Because they always looked
like they were having a blast.
And I have it from her that they
were, indeed, having a blast.
And what I loved about
Carol Burnett was it
was "The Carol Burnett Show".
But it was also the Harvey
Korman show and the Lyle
Waggoner show and the Tim Conway
show and the Vicki Lawrence
show.
They all got to shine.
It wasn't just about her.
She was a member of the
ensemble just as they were.
And I loved that.
KATE FLANNERY:
Which also, I mean,
that's the great
thing about-- I mean,
the big surprise
about Jane's show
is that she actually
shares the stage.
I mean, I feel like that's the
most generous thing you can do.
JANE LYNCH: I don't want
to be out anywhere alone.
I don't.
I don't ever want
to perform alone.
I have no desire.
No desire.
No desire to just
stand there and go, now
here's a story
from my childhood.
KEVIN VALK: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JANE LYNCH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys for coming so much.
My question is
that you both were
on shows that have
kind of become
these cultural icons and
cultural phenomenons, "Glee"
and "The Office".
I'm wondering if you
can talk about one,
what your last day on set with
those great ensembles was like?
And then also if there was a
moment working with the cast
when you felt like this is
really something special.
This is different
than my usual work?
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, well,
I will go first then.
Because I know you
have stories too.
But we just ended.
And one of our last days,
it was almost the last day.
It was like, third to last day.
We did a song, I lived.
That song, I live,
where everybody,
anybody who had guested on
our show was invited to be in.
And tons of them came.
And it was so emotional.
And it was also
dedicating the auditorium
to Cory Monteith's
character, which was
very moving and very, very sad.
And yet, very uplifting
all at the same time.
So that was my big memory,
the big emotional occurrence.
And I remember the pilot.
Shooting the pilot when the
kids were singing don't stop,
believe-- don't stop believing.
And they were just
wearing red t-shirts.
There was no production values.
They were on an empty stage.
And I remember my
character watches it like,
kind of scowling over at them.
And I thought, oh my
god, this is so-- this
is going to be a big hit.
This is.
If it's not a big
hit it's going to be
a small hit with somebody.
You know, that it'll be
a small group of people
that will love it.
But it was so moving and
so raw and so beautiful.
And so that's my "Glee" story.
KATE FLANNERY: I
have to tell you,
I was still waiting tables when
I got the job on "The Office".
So my life completely changed.
I'm kind of a late bloomer.
I've always been working.
But couldn't-- I didn't
quite-- I'm too picky.
And I feel like I didn't
latch on to the right thing.
So when I got "The
Office" I didn't
know what it was going to be.
And initially there
were like, six of us
that were considered guest
stars until the second season.
Then they finally made us
regulars, even though we
were in every episode.
And we were doing Booze Cruise.
We were shooting the
Booze Cruise episode.
And I just remember
feeling like, oh my god.
Like, this is really happening.
This is really happening.
That was the same year we were
first nominated for an Emmy.
And we won.
And I just feel like
my experience, like I
even if I didn't talk for like,
two weeks on that show, like,
I knew I was in something
incredibly special and smart.
And I always felt like
everyone-- especially
the first few years and
Steve Carell in particular,
he was never-- it
was never about him.
Even though he
carried most of it.
He had most of the lines.
He never made it about him.
He always made it about
the work and the ensemble.
And I felt like even
getting the camera
to have a look
had so much power.
So I knew, like, I didn't
have to count my lines.
I didn't have to
judge any of that.
I just trusted
that everything was
going to get revealed
the way it should.
And I'm so happy that that
was actually the case.
And I was so happy
to be the person that
got to do physical comedy.
And I had my own thing.
In
And less was kind of
more but in a great way.
I never felt like I
outwore my welcome.
I feel like people were
really rooting for me.
So I just had an amazing
experience for nine seasons.
And I feel like no
matter what happens,
if I'm only known as a
drunken floozy from that show,
I'm happy.
JANE LYNCH: Not bad.
Not bad.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah,
not too shabby.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KATE FLANNERY: Thank you.
JANE LYNCH: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So you guys
spoke about having
a break between when
you were last on stage
and when you returned
to the stage.
I'm curious of what
you've seen in terms
of differences in the audience.
You mentioned selfies.
You mentioned photos.
I guess you missed
sort of the beginning
of the big technology,
sort of blast.
JANE LYNCH: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious what you've seen
and also how that impacted
you as a performer
and how you deal with that?
JANE LYNCH: It
hasn't-- you know,
because when I went back to
Broadway-- back to Broadway.
Actually, it was
my Broadway debut.
But it was me going
back to theater.
The audiences changed
because on Broadway it's
a lot of tourists.
And it didn't change the
way any of us performed.
But I noticed that
nobody's dressing up
to go to the theater anymore.
There's a lot of cargo
shorts and fanny packs.
KEVIN VALK: A lot of this.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
And but you know, that's OK.
And I think this
always happened,
at least in the
last 10 or 15 years.
If there's a star
on Broadway there's
always a line of people
at the stage door
who want photographs
and autographs.
And that certainly wasn't
the case when the last time
I did theater.
And there's a lot
more electronic media,
like Broadway.com does a
whole electronic media thing.
But it really hasn't
effect- it did not
affect at all the way I perform
or my experience on stage.
It was just a joy to go back.
But things definitely
have changed.
KATE FLANNERY: I just
remember actually Jane
and I did the same play in New
York but at different times.
So it was Nora Ephron's play
"Love, Loss, and What I Wore".
And I did it, I
think, five years ago.
I think I did it like,
a year after you did.
JANE LYNCH: Mhm.
KATE FLANNERY: And I
remember someone's phone
rang in the audience.
And they actually took the call.
And they were talking.
And the audience
wanted to kill them.
I said something.
I said, I had some
killer snappy comeback.
JANE LYNCH: I'm sure you did.
Whakka.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah,
but I still felt
like I couldn't stop
what was happening.
But I felt like the audience
sort of shut it down.
So I've never seen that before.
That's kind of been like,
that was like, the major like,
what is happening?
There is sort of an
unconscious thing
that happens with live shows.
But I think that's part of
we're all sort of negotiating
this new technology.
And there is no protocol.
There should be.
But there's not.
Like, people that used to have
to go to a telephone booth
before and now there's no booth.
So you know.
But I think that, unfortunately,
theatre's really expensive.
But it doesn't keep out the
people that are unconscious.
They have money too.
JANE LYNCH: I've seen people
get up to go to the bathroom
like they're at a movie theater.
And I would just
never think about it.
I wouldn't do that.
Because when you get up,
there are live people up there
who are focusing on something.
And you're like, excuse me.
And then they come back.
And they waddle
back down the aisle.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah,
they don't wait
for like, a break in
the-- like, you know,
there's no consciousness.
JANE LYNCH: They shouldn't
let them back in too, I think.
KATE FLANNERY: Punishment.
JANE LYNCH: You
should have to wait.
Because there's monitors in the
lobby for most of the theaters.
You can watch the play
from a monitor in the lobby
if you want.
KEVIN VALK: So has that
been fun for you guys?
Because with social media,
with Instagram and Twitter
and everything, and Facebook,
like going out and like,
touching your fans, being
able to engage with them,
has that been pretty cool?
KATE FLANNERY: It's
kind of horrifying.
KEVIN VALK: You
have to be careful.
KATE FLANNERY: It is.
It's a little horrifying.
Because there is
a sense of-- like,
I have to be a little
more self conscious
than I normally would be.
And I just have
to figure out, OK,
what, who needs to know what?
Like, and also like,
who gives a flying shit?
I just feel like sometimes
there's-- I remember having
to do, like, a celebrity
blog for "The Office".
Like, I did "The Office"
blog for TVGuide.com.
And I thought, someone did
it before me who was like,
we all had raisins today.
Like, they were saying
like, the dumbest things.
And I felt like I needed
to have a point of view.
So I was like, you know,
who's the drunk in the corner
watching everybody?
But for me I just feel
like sometimes there's
such an egocentric
thing that happens
with a sense of celebrity,
even at the smallest level.
But I think we're
all sort of like,
negotiating your
ability to stick around,
people's-- you know, it's
like you can't-- I don't know.
I just think it's a
really slippery slope.
But people are great.
And I do love the fans.
I do the Twitter.
I do it all.
But it is like, oh my god.
I mean, if somebody had told
me this like, years ago,
that this was what it
was going to evolve to,
I mean, I don't know.
I don't know if I would've
signed up exactly.
I mean Jane gets stopped.
You get stopped
way more than I do.
And you handle it so well.
JANE LYNCH: No I don't.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah you do.
JANE LYNCH: Not these days.
I can be really rude these
day.s you've seen it.
But yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: But sometimes
enough is enough though.
JANE LYNCH: If it's
a child I'll be nice.
Yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: Yes.
KEVIN VALK: What if it's an
adult acting like a child?
JANE LYNCH: But even
they're pushing it
at this point, the kids.
KATE FLANNERY: Well, there
is an expectation though.
That's the problem.
JANE LYNCH: Yes, there
is an expectation.
It's almost like you're a prize.
You're the thing they're
going to put on their shelf.
And I don't like that.
I'll be walking down the street
and someone just comes right up
to me and goes, in my face.
Not even like, hey.
First of all, I wouldn't
want to talk to you anyway.
Probably wouldn't have
been nice to you anyway.
But it's just this
trying to get a prize.
This isn't it all
what you asked, is it?
KEVIN VALK: No,
that was my fault.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
I think it's absolutely
related because I actually
saw a production in
Pasadena Playhouse
with Laurence Fishburne.
And he walked on stage
and everybody burst
into applause in the
middle of the scene
and interrupted the play.
That had to hold for applause.
JANE LYNCH: That
happens on Broadway too.
That is kind of a
tradition, actually.
When the star comes
out, they used to do it
with Lunt and Fontanne.
They would come out and
everybody would applaud them.
But now it's become kind of
like, you were in a movie!
Woo!
Matrix!
Yeah, that is.
And it does.
It does take away from it.
Yeah, it does.
No, that's one of the
things that I don't like.
But it's been around
for a long time.
I don't know if that
makes it better.
Because it's been
around for a long time.
KEVIN VALK: I think the
alternative is I mean,
you guys have the show that's
going around the country
and you're able to actually
engage people and be like, I'm
going to be in your town.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: It's
is kind of great.
Although sometimes it feels
like this is your life.
Because there's somebody
that will show up
that I was like, oh, my old
roommate from 15 years ago
that I've lost touch with.
Probably for a good reason.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's funky.
But it's also fantastic
in a good way.
KEVIN VALK: Very cool.
JANE LYNCH: More questions about
how hard it is to be a star.
KEVIN VALK: How much they
hate this generation.
AUDIENCE: First of all, thanks
to both of you for coming here
to come speak with us today.
I'm was just
wondering, what's it
like when you, either of you,
when you run into Second City
alums?
Like you're doing
a show or a movie.
Like, for example,
I know both of you
have worked with Steve
Carell on things.
You know, "40-year-old
Virgin" and "The Office".
So hoping you'd speak
a little on that.
JANE LYNCH: It's
wonderful because we
have a shared history
that they were definitely
the salad days for us.
But they were really
creative times.
Chicago's a really
wonderful place
to start your artistic career.
It's full of people who are
self starters who are doing it
because they love it.
And it attracts people from
all over the world, really, who
kind of want to start
their own theater company
and want to work on stage and
love it for the art of it.
And so it's kind of nice
to run into somebody
like, hey, remember back then?
And the wardrobe person
on "Glee" used to say I
could always tell
a Chicago actor.
They hang up their clothes.
Because we hang up our
clothes because we're
going to have to wear them
the next day and there's
nobody cleaning them for us.
But there's just yeah, it's
kind of artistic centric.
And so when you run into each
other it's almost like a relief
like, oh, you know,
there's somebody
who I used to make funny with.
And we used to go out
drinking and have parties.
So it's kind of nice to connect.
KATE FLANNERY: It is great.
And the other thing
I was going to say,
the whole award show phenomenon,
that is so fantastic.
Because there's people that
I would see from Second City
that I'd only see at the
Emmys or at the Golden Globes.
And it'd be like, oh my god.
You know, it's
like, such a weird--
it's like we're on
this weird planet
that we're so lucky to get
to, whether we win or not.
It doesn't even matter.
It's like we're at
this crazy party
and Tony Bennett is singing
five feet in front of us
for no reason.
So it's this weird thing.
But it's a nice validation for
all the weird-- all the growing
and the stumbling
and all that stuff.
It's like, it's just so nice
to get to enjoy those moments
and to realize like, it
doesn't matter what you get.
Just being there is
really the prize.
Thanks.
JANE LYNCH: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
KATE FLANNERY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to
say, first off, thank you
for all the work you do for
PETA and animal protection.
That's very worthy.
JANE LYNCH: Love the animals.
AUDIENCE: Are you
going to miss "Glee"?
And what part of it do you
think you'll miss the most?
If you miss it.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
you know, yeah.
Well, you know, we did
in the Paramount lot.
And I have a new
TV show now on CBS
that's I start shooting soon
called "Angel From Hell".
And we're shooting
on Paramount lot.
And we're not on
the "Glee" stages.
But our production offices are
the "Glee" production offices.
So it's kind of funny
to be back there, just
a different show
and different faces.
I became close with Matt
Morrison and Darren Criss.
And they're both
on Broadway now.
And I got to see them.
And so there's a part of it
that's like, yeah, it was done.
And I have the
friends, the people who
popped for me are still around.
So Dot-Marie Jones,
and I still see
these people which is great.
Chris Colfer lives
two blocks from me.
So I see him all the time.
AUDIENCE: Are you're
going to record
this particular show at all?
Or do some form of recording?
JANE LYNCH: Yes.
I think we did one.
We recorded the one in
Merrillville, Indiana.
Which is great because
it was all of our peeps.
Because it's about 20
minutes from Chicago.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah, a lot
of your high school friends
were there, right?
Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: I think--
you know what?
We might be-- Joe's
Pub we might-- yeah,
hopefully it'll be something.
I think we might actually do
a production where we do it
on purpose and maybe have a
live feed and an album from it.
They're kind of talking
about that sort of thing
but nothing's for sure yet.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KATE FLANNERY: But
there's nothing better
than coming to the theater.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
It is.
AUDIENCE: If I were going
to be around absolutely.
JANE LYNCH: I love it.
KATE FLANNERY: Cheap
promotion, sorry.
JANE LYNCH: We're going to be
in Long Beach for all of you
out here, if you wanted
to take a little ride.
KATE FLANNERY: October 3rd.
JANE LYNCH: October 3rd.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: Which
will be a great show.
KATE FLANNERY: Go to Jane Lynch
official for all the dates.
JANE LYNCH: Yes, and I think
it's at The Carpenter Center?
KATE FLANNERY: The
Carpenter Center, yes.
JANE LYNCH: Richard and
Karen Carpenter actually--
KATE FLANNERY: Oh I'm sorry.
I went to Jesus.
I'm sorry.
And they are like Jesus.
JANE LYNCH: The most
famous carpenter.
KATE FLANNERY: Yes, right.
JANE LYNCH: Next
to Harrison Ford,
who you know was a carpenter.
KATE FLANNERY: Oh
I didn't know that.
Wow.
That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JANE LYNCH: You're welcome.
KATE FLANNERY: Thanks.
KEVIN VALK: You both
are phenomenal singers.
And I didn't realize, actually,
you sang until this whole thing
kind of came along.
And so when you guys
weren't doing the show,
was there kind of coming back
into practice with all this?
KATE FLANNERY: Well, I actually
have a comedy lounge act.
So I've been singing for
15 years just doing that.
JANE LYNCH: The
Lampshade, it's called.
KATE FLANNERY: We're
called The Lampshades.
we're like a dying lounge act.
We do mash ups of
'70s and '80s songs.
KEVIN VALK: Right.
KATE FLANNERY: But my partner
Lampshades, Scott Robinson,
does not sing harmony.
So the reason why
we do mash ups is
because we can only sing
two songs at the same time.
That's like, our trick.
JANE LYNCH: But that's great.
KATE FLANNERY: It's like, our
weakness became our strength.
If that makes any sense.
KEVIN VALK: Yeah, yeah yeah.
KATE FLANNERY: So yeah.
But that feels different
because it's like,
it's a little more
of a character.
So I sort of make fun of singers
when I sing as a Lampshade.
Because it's like, all the
people that are super self
indulgent that kind
of drive me crazy.
But so getting to sing
with Jane is like,
this very legitimate like, you
either got it or you don't.
You either get
there or you don't.
JANE LYNCH: And
we've gotten better.
KATE FLANNERY: Oh yeah.
JANE LYNCH: I mean, we weren't
too shabby when we started out.
But my voice is better
than it's ever been.
KATE FLANNERY: No, absolutely.
JANE LYNCH: It's true.
KATE FLANNERY: We
could do Utah again.
You would not need
oxygen. I know that.
We would be super fine.
JANE LYNCH: If we
were in Utah today
we would not be sucking
that oxygen off stage.
They literally had a
machine where you could go--
KATE FLANNERY: It was so funny.
I remember the first time
we did the show in New York.
And you said, you're
as good as me!
That is high praise baby.
JANE LYNCH: We
had just rehearsed
and, oh, I was so
pleased with us.
KATE FLANNERY: Well, no,
because you don't give it away.
I mean, you don't-- you
know, she's not full of shit.
If you get a compliment
it's genuine.
She's not emailing it in.
JANE LYNCH: You're
as good as me.
How's that for a compliment?
I knew she would get it though.
KEVIN VALK: I know
you guys packed
the show with a ton of songs.
But are there any songs that you
would like to get into the show
that you didn't
get in, you're kind
of this well-oiled machine?
JANE LYNCH: If we find a song
that we want to get in we
will put it in.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah.
I think so.
I mean, we talked about
doing some Roches songs,
which we might.
JANE LYNCH: Well, we
could still do that.
KATE FLANNERY: Maybe Christmas.
JANE LYNCH: You know the Roches?
Y'all should check them out.
They're three sisters
from New Jersey.
And they were
popular in the '70s.
And they do these crazy
three-part harmonies,
but hilarious lyrics.
KATE FLANNERY: A
lot of a cappella.
JANE LYNCH: A lot of a cappella.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah, so good.
JANE LYNCH: Some of the
songs are hilarious.
And some of them
were very moving.
So we will look into that maybe.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah, there
might be some Christmas material
perhaps?
JANE LYNCH: Oh, perhaps we
might do a very crazy version
of the Hallelujah Chorus.
KATE FLANNERY: Oh yeah.
JANE LYNCH: It'll be legit, the
actual parts and everything.
But we'll do it really fast.
Right?
KATE FLANNERY: No pressure.
JANE LYNCH: No pressure.
No rehearsal.
No pressure, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: That's probably
going to happen in December.
KEVIN VALK: And it would
be awkward in March.
JANE LYNCH: No, well
actually, that's
when he is risen,
according to the timeline
of this whole thing.
Hallelujah Chorus
is he has risen.
And we do at Christmas.
And it's just the
timeline's off.
KATE FLANNERY: It's
an Easter song.
I'm going to talk to
the new pope about that.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, right.
KEVIN VALK: So looking back
at your guys careers, what
were just, like, the most
memorable times and the most
fun times in your career?
I mean obviously,
you guys are on TV
and have so much success in
the past couple decades here.
JANE LYNCH: It's funny, music
is in every memory for me.
That's the best.
When we did a Mighty Wind,
rehearsing a Mighty Wind,
the music, because we
didn't rehearse the acting.
Because there was no rehearsal
for Christopher Guest movies.
But we rehearsed the music.
And then we went on tour.
And that was so much fun.
That was a highlight.
And you know, this,
what we're doing now.
And "The Real Live Brady
Bunch" was a lot of fun too.
But yeah, mostly
it's the-- god, those
were the heady days. "The
Real Live Brady Bunch",
that was so much fun.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah, that
was like such a journey
for all of us involved.
Like, we were learning so much.
And there was such a
sense of possibility.
Jill Soloway was our director
and her sister Faith.
And it was like,
there was a sense--
she was-- Jill was totally
fearless even back then.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, Jill
created "Transparent".
KATE FLANNERY: Fearless.
JANE LYNCH: And is the
executive producer on that.
She was like, 27 years old.
And she's dealing
with these guys
in New York, these
theater guys in New York,
getting us a great deal.
We did it at the Village Gate.
KATE FLANNERY: Amazing.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah,
she was fearless.
KATE FLANNERY: Great negotiator.
But really great
creative person.
She had it all.
And like, in some ways I'm so
surprised it took her 20 years
for "Transparent" to happen.
Because I would have
assumed it would
have happened 20 years ago.
JANE LYNCH: She was
no slouch before that.
KATE FLANNERY: No.
No.
But it's even sweeter
because yeah, I mean, yeah.
JANE LYNCH: This is her story.
You know, her dad really,
at the 70 decided he was
a woman, kind of out of nowhere.
KATE FLANNERY: So
it's interesting.
So we've had like, well, that's
another shared that we have.
Like, this kind of
experience of someone
who kind of shepherded all
of us to kind of take it
to another level and
to realize that we
could reach a new dream, like
a different-- our own kind
of dream.
Like, really follow
our own personal bliss,
which is unusual.
Because usually, when
you go to theater school,
sometimes there's kind
of regimented thing
that is kind of expected
and go to New York
or do regional theater.
And you know, and
maybe getting paid shit
and then getting paid great
for doing what you really
love doing is such a rare--
it's like, it's the greatest.
I mean, you guys know.
You work at Google.
You must be paid millions.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah,
you're Googlers.
KATE FLANNERY: Right?
KATE FLANNERY: But
seriously, there's
something so important
about having that peace.
I don't know.
I feel so privileged.
And it's always worth the wait.
I mean, that's why I didn't
mind waiting tables longer.
Because everything
was worth the wait.
I don't know, I had some
sense of faith about it.
But I think it came
from Chicago days.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah, I do too.
Yeah, keep if fun
or don't do it.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you
guys for being here so much.
[APPLAUSE]
JANE LYNCH: Being here so much?
Too much?
KEVIN VALK: So "See Jane Sing",
playing at UC Davis tomorrow
night.
Ocean Beach October 3rd.
KATE FLANNERY: Long Beach.
KEVIN VALK: Long Beach, sorry.
JANE LYNCH: Long Beach, yeah.
KEVIN VALK: Sorry.
Long Beach October 3rd.
And then New York.
JANE LYNCH: Yeah,
Joe's Pub is coming up.
KEVIN VALK: Joe's Pub.
August 16, 17, 18, 19.
JANE LYNCH: It's the dead
days of August in New York.
And it would be really nice to
get some people in the theatre.
KEVIN VALK: Absolutely.
KATE FLANNERY:
Jane Lynch Official
or Twitter or Instagram.
She's on everything.
JANE LYNCH: Joe's Pub.
KATE FLANNERY: Yeah.
KEVIN VALK: All right,
thank you guys so much.
JANE LYNCH: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]